chief executive two or three years it
sounded like nobody wanted to stay in
Afghanistan from NATO and now they all
agreed to stay longer what's changed
they are more sure about the capability
of the Afghan government in the
performance of the unity government as
well as well as our security forces that
they know that the challenge of
terrorism worldwide and also in our
region is a growing one but at the same
time the will and determination of the
Afghan people as well as our forces to
deal with them with big sacrifices that
has encouraged our partners 12 upon us
on until it's achieves the goal of
self-reliance don't you think it's more
because the security situation in
Afghanistan isn't where it should be the
security situation is not where it
should be but at the same time a few
years ago most of the responsibility was
on the shoulders of the international
forces today it's the Afghan forces
which is carrying out those
responsibilities in the need to continue
to support is recognized and we are
happy and we are grateful for our
partners to be forthcoming in terms of
assuring Afghanistan about their
continued commitment how long do you
think the NATO will have to stay when
will you be able to do all that by
yourself five years ten years give us a
number didn't I don't think that you
need a number this is stage or I don't
think that I I know the number but at
the same time I know that this year will
be a tough year for us in hopefully
beyond this we will have a much better
horizon to see the future more clearly
and then based on that decide on the
nature of partnership between NATO and
Afghanistan chief executive thank you
very much for talking to us